how can we live free government imposes
so many rules many of which we don't
agree with so what could we do not happy
with the way government runs how about
starting your own country build a city
in the ocean
it's called seasteading the idea is that
if people move at least 12 miles
offshore they can build their own cities
or country and live free from government
suffocating rules unfortunately nothing
like this has been built yet this is
just an animation showing what sea
Stead's might look like in the future
the first season but this year
chad and nadia lor tao ski set up this
small sea stood 13 miles off the coast
of Thailand looking forward to
freedom-loving people to come join us
out in the open ocean as long as people
can create these sea Stead's voluntarily
and people can quit them voluntarily
then you'll have a market of competing
governance providers joke work runs the
seasteading Institute which promotes the
floating islands we need a new place to
experiment with new rules appropriate
for modern technologies what a great
idea
unfortunately that first sea stood
recently came to a bad end more on that
shortly but first let's hear more about
the idea innovators innovating in the
21st century are being held back by
rules written in the 1970s but we need
some rule these debtors don't have a
problem with regulations per se humans
need rules to interact we have a problem
with the monopoly over the provision and
enforcement of regulations liberate
humanity from politicians yes
we don't need politicians they're not
smart enough to make decisions for us
without American rules some will be
shooting up heroin or abusing children
we have that in our country right now
but if I move 12 miles offshore and I'm
gonna be so incentivized to set a better
example because the world's eyes are
gonna be on me
I gotta convince investors to invest in
it I got to convince people to move
there I got to convince people to take
jobs there I
in such an environment it's going to be
much more difficult to create evil
islands of heroin shooting than it is to
create positive innovations that improve
people's lives
we at carnival believe fun is a choice
he says the world already has a form of
C stands the cruise ship most cruise
ships fly the flag of say Panama or
Liberia and they're sort of de facto
self-governing Liberia has no capacity
to like enforce rules on the three and a
half thousand ships that fly its flag so
a captain is a de facto dictator
why doesn't he become a tyrant and the
answer is is because people can choose
another cruise line the sea studying
instance who it approaches politicians
saying we'll bring our own land we'll
float just offshore and if it succeeds
we share in the prosperity if it fails
we absorb the cost mines can be opened
to a little bit more freedom a little
further out to shore mines were opened
in China when tiny Hong Kong showed that
having fewer rules could bring
prosperity China very rapidly because of
the example set by Hong Kong started
creating these special economic zones
special economic zones are similar to
ceased it's they have fewer rules at
least a half billion Chinese people have
exited extreme poverty by moving to
these new jurisdictions so why don't the
Chinese leaders or any political leaders
say this works we'll do it for the whole
country never for the whole country why
not
I would I would too but that's why you
and I don't have political power
unfortunately in China those with
political power didn't want to give it
up they did not expand freedom to the
whole country so something like
seasteading would be an important
experiment Chad and Nadia hoped there
ceased it would be the first of many
it's gonna grow bigger and bigger they
thought they would do a demonstration
project of this tiny cabin and
demonstrate the world that they can make
it cheap and they thought nobody would
care to everyone's surprise the Thai
Navy took exception to this to aspiring
seas debtors have had their property
raided by the Thai Navy pair Nadia left
their Island
shortly before the raid they got nervous
when they saw a reconnaissance plane
flying overhead now they're on the run
it could in theory face the death
penalty for violating Thai sovereignty
that would be quite a price for trying
to live on the high seas it's
irresponsible not to improve society by
setting better examples and I think
people with the best ideas should be
given an opportunity to do that
voluntarily and pay the consequences of
their failures and get the profits if
they succeed good for Chad and Nadia for
trying